hi I'm Matt Welch I'm here with my
co-author Nick Gillespie on ask a
libertarian day we have a two-part
question first part by Stephen Noel ski
how can libertarians condemn
intellectual property related wall Damir
Inc doll this is the best first name so
far we've had via Twitter so what's the
libertarian perspective on net
neutrality okay and we we think there
these are related questions or I do
Stephen as how can libertarians condemn
intellectual property liberty
intellectual property in the
Constitution is talked about as a
government grant of Monopoly for a
limited period of time to push progress
in science and the useful arts so it's
it's a creation of government it does
not exist in nature in the same way that
property in ourselves does and even that
you got to fight for it all the time
beyond that intellectual property is a
classic case in the Constitution it says
you get a monopoly on the returns of
your invention or your creation for a
limited period of time that time has
constantly been upgraded and upgraded
and upgraded totally at the behest of
major corporations or major politically
connected people who get their way with
the legislature intellectual property
just from an empirical point of view
there is no reason to believe for
instance that copyright strike and
copyright protections help artists or
help society with during the big Napster
hoo-ha years ago the groups that were
being downloaded the most illegally on
Napster we're also seeing the biggest
sales online or rather in legitimate
forum so there's a lot there to think
about when we talk about net neutrality
this is another case where net
neutrality however you talk about it it
comes down to a government group whether
it's the FCC or some other panel
controlling the on-ramp the off-ramp or
the actual traffic flow on the Internet
we don't need it there have been
effectively no cases where net
neutrality the idea that you can get
anything you want on the internet any
source any stream etc where it's been
and pay
we don't need it and it would just
introduce another level of government
regulation to a place that has been list
fully free of that kind of distortion
it's a solution in search of a problem
in the classic sense and I recommend to
anyone watching this treat Peter Souter
man's great feature on how we live now
unfortunately in a net neutrality
universe